welcome everybody to today's seminar on
lipids lipidomics and its application in
pharmaceutical and biomarker research
i'm christiane cto at lipotype and
responsible for r d
lipotype is a lipidomic service provider
based in the eastern germany
we are providing epidomics analysis
services based on our shotgun mass
spectrometry technology
and we are the first and worldwide only
gmp certified
lipidomics laboratory we have a spin-off
of the max planck institute of molecular
cell biology and genetics
and lipotype was founded by its ceo
professor kaizemons who is one of the
leading researchers
in the field of lipid and membrane
biology
as our shotgun epidomics technology is
applicable to a wide range of sample
types
we find our customers in very different
fields
first of all in biotech and pharma we
support for example in clinical research
and drug discovery
for the food industry we are for example
involved in intervention studies for the
development of functional foods
and with our skin lipidomics technology
we work for the cosmetics industry in
the areas of claim support the topical
drug development
and finally we support academic
researchers by analyzing lipids in
various model organisms
what is our philosophy and our
motivation why do we do epidemics
with our vision lipidomics for a better
life we want to increase the information
about state of an individual's health
today when you go to the doctor only two
lipid parameters are analyzed
triglycerides and cholesterol
these parameters are used for the
assessment of risk of cardiovascular
diseases
but there are more than hundreds of
additional parameters the triglycerides
have different fatty acid compositions
they differ for example in saturation
and chain length the same is true for
the esterified cholesterol
in addition to triglycerides and
cholesterol many other lipids exist
which are not measured in the clinic for
example phospholipids and sphingolipids
our goal is to make use of this
information make it available
for the assessment of health and disease
at the molecular level by means of
lipidomics
and i will show you later how far we got
with this
what is lipidomics epidomics is the
large-scale study
of pathways and networks of cellular
lipids and biological systems
analogous to genomics transcriptomics
and proteomics which deal with the study
of genes transcripts and proteins
respectively
the lipid complement of an organism is
studied by lipidomics
lipidomics as part of metabolomics shown
here
which deals with metabolites but
lipidomics is special
because lipids are not water-soluble and
have specific structural features
which pose their analysis challenging
despite their uniqueness
they are an integral part of cells
tissues and organisms
by playing central roles in energy
metabolism as signaling molecules
and as building blocks of cellular
structures
epidemics clearly is an emerging
technology in 2012 when liver type was
founded there were about 200 papers
listed in pubmed with the keyword
epidomics
last year in 2020 there were more than 1
500 lipidomics papers published a
15-fold increase in 10 years
this shows that lipids are gaining more
and more attention in a wide range of
different research areas
which reflects their ubiquitous presence
for examples for example lipids are a
central building block of our skin
namely
they form the stratum corneum the
outermost layer
of our bodies maintaining a tight
barrier against pathogens contaminations
and the evaporation of water
furthermore lipids are nutrients in our
diet once eaten they enter our
bloodstream and structures called
lipoprotein particles
these lipoproteins consist of an outer
shell of phospholipids
at the core of neutral storage lipids
the triglycerides and cholesterol
easters the lipoproteins are the
vehicles used by our bodies to transport
lipids to the various organs
where they serve as nutrients and
building blocks for cellular structures
in the form of membranes cellular
membranes
are a bilayer of lipids that surround
our cells and form intracellular
structures the organelles
not only do they form these surroundings
but they are also the medium in which
transmembrane proteins are embedded as
shown here
about 30 of the proteome are
transmembrane proteins many of which
play important roles in cell cell
signaling
interactions and signaling processes
that are fundamental to disease
mechanisms in for example
diabetes and cancer however
it is not at all it is not
that all membranes are alike they differ
significantly
in their lipid composition resulting in
different biophysical properties
for example the plasma membrane is shown
here surrounding the cell
shows high concentrations of cholesterol
saturated phospholipids and single
lipids
compared with other organelles such as
the endoplasmic reticulum
shown here all the golgi are parallels
shown here
the membrane composition is fine tuned
to its function in case of the plasma
membrane
this is to form the outermost border of
the cell and to be able to form dynamic
nanoscopic membrane domains called lipid
rafts which play important roles in
cellular signaling
in cellular signaling events
the variations in membrane compositions
and hence differences in membrane
properties of the different cylinder
subcompartments
are achieved by stunning structural
diversity of lipid molecules
in theory there can be tens of thousands
of different lipid molecules
how so you see
lipids are made of building blocks many
of them consist of a charged head group
shown here in green and the hydrophobic
part
usually made up of hydrocarbon chains
shown here
examples are phospholipids up here and
glycerophospholipids down here
to a large degree the structural
diversity is achieved by variations in
the hydrophobic part of the molecules
the fatty acids here
they can have different lengths or
different numbers of positions
or positions of double bonds and they
can be bound to the lipid backbone in
different ways
for example by easter or ether bonds as
shown here
and these variations give rise to
different lipid species or subspecies
variations in the lipid head groups here
in green and here
give rise to different lipid classes so
now while combinatorically the
possibilities are almost endless the
actual lipid composition of an organism
is limited by its complement of lipid
synthesizing enzymes
and their substrate specificities
therefore with modern analytical
techniques
a few thousand lipid molecules can be
detected in mammals
the actual composition depending on the
type of body fluid tissue or organ
that is analyzed
historically the lipid composition of
biological samples
was analyzed by thin layer
chromatography
shown here this method allows for the
analysis of
the lipid composition on the lipid class
level for example phosphatidylcholine or
phosphatidylethanolamine shown here
that means that by lipid molecules the
various charged head groups can be
nicely separated
in forms of bands here
information on the presence of
quantities of individual lipid molecules
can typically not be easily obtained
this changed when analytical scientists
started to exploit
the power of mass spectrometry in order
to analyze lipids at the molecular level
as you can see here these are mass
spectra showing peaks for each
individual
lipid molecule this development led to
the rise of lipidomics
now with the availability of high
resolution mass analyzers in benchtop
format
mass spectrometry has become the gold
standard for the qualitative and
quantitative lipid analysis
at the molecular level how does lipid
analysis in the mass spec work
a mass spectrum as shown here in the top
panel has an
x-axis showing the masses of the
detected molecules
and the y-axis showing the signal
intensity
the signal intensity corresponds to the
abundance of a molecule the more there
is of a given molecule
the higher the intensity the lipid
molecules can now be annotated based on
their molecular mass which obviously
is based on the elemental composition
in order to obtain quantitative results
typically internal standards are used
for
normalization like here in green these
are spiked that no one amounts to the
sample before lipid extraction and mass
spec analysis and la and allow
for the calculation of molecular
concentrations or
molar concentrations actually
during the mass spec analysis the intake
lipid molecules can be subjected to
fragmentation as shown here in the lower
panel
this gives rise to building block
specific fragment spectra as shown down
here
in this example fragmentation allows us
to determine the exact fatty acid
composition
of the lipid molecule so we see a
fragment for the oleic acid fragment
and the peak for the palmitic acid
fragment
therefore mass spectrometry allows for
both quantitative and structural
analysis in a single
in a single run for each sample
this is a typical shotgun epidomics
workflow lipids and biological samples
are extracted with organic solvents
using a fully automated pipetting robot
in 96 well format
lipid extracts are then directly infused
into the mass back by a robot
by robotic nano electrospray ionization
source
also in 96 well format shown here then
the mass spectra are acquired on q
executives with high resolution
orbitrack technology shown here
after the mass spectra are required the
lipid identification is performed with a
dedicated software called lipotype
explorer
during that step the masses in the mass
spectra are turned into actual lipids
and finally statistical analysis is done
this may include simple t-tests
multivariate analysis
pathway and enrichment analysis but also
sophisticated machine learning
approaches
the libertarian shotgun lipidomics
technology provides a broad range of
broad coverage of lipids in total we can
detect
more than 3 000 individual lipid
molecules in more than 50 different
lipid classes
the technology is applicable to a large
variety of sample types such as
body fluids like blood plasma blood
serum but also cellular material
microorganisms
and skin and tissue and organ samples
another advantage of this technology is
that we require only minimal sample
amounts per analysis for example
one microliter of blood plasma is
sufficient or
about 100 000 cells of a cell culture
sample
i would now like to turn to some
applications of the shotgun epidomics
technology
the first will deal with lipid biomarker
identification in large chord studies
and the other one will be about the use
of lipidomics and the understanding of
molecular mechanisms of cancer
in a recent publication we have
identified a lipidomic blood signature
for obesity together with our co-workers
from the university of helsinki in
finland and lund and sweden
we asked ourselves the question is
health reflected in the lipido
and if so what is the information
content compared with classical clinical
parameters
we wanted to assess that for the example
of obesity because it is a risk factor
for several diseases
like coronary heart disease stroke type
2 diabetes
metabolic syndrome and cancer
there are different ways to measure
obesity body mass index
bmi waist to hip ratio and body fat
percentage
and in order to address the question
whether obesity is reflected in the
human plasma we analyzed more than 5
000 plasma samples using our shotgun
epidemics technology
from two different cohorts the miami
diet and cancer study
and the fin risk study these are
population by cohorts with extensive
longitudinal medical records
based on the lipidomics data from
finrisk we built a mathematical model
with obesity as outcome
the model was then validated in the
completely independent minor cohort
as i said we used obesity as outcome and
obesity
was based was measured as body fat
percentage
raise to hip ratio and bmi
we first wanted to know which parameter
is best reflected in the lipidome and
you can see here the result
of the cross validation for the
different obesity readouts in terms of
cross-validation error
here on the y-axis of the graph the
lower the error
the better that parameter is reflected
in the lippy dome and it turns out that
body fat percentage works best while bmi
is not so well reflected in the blood
lippy dome
having a higher cross-validation error
than the other two parameters
as i mentioned earlier the obesity model
was built on the finished cohort
and validated in the swedish coord the
result for that
validation is shown here one can see
that the validation error
here in green is not so much different
from the cross validation error
and also from the training and the
testing error indicating that
overfitting does not seem to be an issue
and the model is robustly working and
completely independent
sample and data set
when looking at the lipids that are used
by the model in order to reflect the
obesity state of subject it turns out
that they are distributed across the
entire lipidome
the tick marks in this figure indicate
the lipids used by the mathematical
model
there are for example triglycerides
shown here
and cholesterol easters shown here this
is not surprising
it mainly confirms that obese people
have high levels of triglycerides and
cholesterol in their blood
the fact that also many phospholipids
and finger lipids as shown here
phosphatidylcholine single myelin and
many other phospholipids
a part of the obesity signature
indicates that the aberrations of lipid
metabolism and obesity go way beyond
triglycerides and cholesterol and this
is confirmed by the following analysis
but before proceeding with that one
needs to know that there are different
layers of information in the lipidome
based on different structural levels
levels so we have lipid categories such
as glycerol phospholipids glycerolipids
and so on
but also lipid classes like the
phosphatidylcholines triglycerides
cholesterol easters
and then lipid species and subspecies
with more and more structural
information available on the different
levels on the hierarchy
so now we have used these different
levels of lipid information in order to
determine
obesity in different subjects
when using only clinical information
such as classical cholesterol data
shown here with a black line we get a
quite high error for the obesity
prediction so in this graph the error
for the prediction is shown here on the
y-axis
when we now add more and more lipid
information like the blue line here
lipid categories
green line lipid classes and then orange
and red lipid species and subspecies
our assessment of obesity becomes better
and better
this shows that the lipidum is much more
informative than classical clinical
parameters
and that molecular details matter for
the understanding of obesity
so that results sort of closes the
circle to our motivation presented
earlier
to make use of molecular lipid
information in the assessment of health
and disease
i would now like to turn to the last
topic of my presentation and that is the
role of lipidomics in understanding
disease mechanisms
in cancer many of you
are probably familiar with the hallmarks
of cancer proposed by hanahan and
weinberg
in 2011 they added deregulating cellular
energetics as an emerging hallmark
shown here cellular energetics
that includes lipid metabolism and
consequently today there are
several drug candidates in the pipeline
that target lipid metabolism
for example drugs targeting the fatty
acid transporter cd36
fascist fatty acid synthetase
but also the fatty acid desaturates as
cd to name only a few
but how are lipids mechanistically
linked to cancer
this is the schematic presentation of
the vulnerability of cancer cells
towards inhibition of fatty acid
desaturation under the metabolic
metabolically
compromised conditions of the two more
microenvironment
meaning tumor cells that are very
distant
from the blood vasculature actually
scientists believe that tumor cells are
exposed to conditions of reduced
availability of exogenous lipids
because of the distance from the blood
vasculature making them vulnerable
towards inhibition of fatty acid
desaturation
the inhibition of the fatty acid
saturates here shown in the left
on the right hand side of the panel
causes relative accumulation of
saturated fatty acids
and disturbs cardiolipin compositions
cardiolipin
is an important lipid in mitochondria
and this results in release of
cytochrome c
reduced mitochondrial activity enhanced
sensitivity towards chemotherapeutic
drugs
and reduce tumor growth
in another more recent example the
authors could show that genomic
aberrations in cancer cells
result in increased activity of an acyl
transferase
this in turn leads to an increase in
saturated phosphatidylcholine lipids
in the cellular membranes now this in
turn again
leads to an increased activity of
oncogenic receptors such as
the epidermal growth factor receptor
which results in enhanced tumor
progression and poor survival rates
in another study that applied lipotype
shotgun epidemics technology the authors
found out how lipid synthesizing enzymes
drive prostaglandin synthesis which is
required for cancer proliferation
the starting point for icosanoid and
prostaglandin synthesis
is arachidonic acid highlighted here
this is a fatty acid produced by
phospholipase a
which cleaves the arachidonic acid of
the membrane phospholipid precursors
an aragonic acid then serves as this as
the starting point for the synthesis of
various icosanoids or prostaglandins
as shown here in this scheme
so it's known that prostaglandins
promote tumor growth by
directly activating signaling pathways
which control cancer cell proliferation
anchorage independent growth cellular
migration and apoptosis
as mentioned earlier arachidonic acid is
produced from membrane phospholipids
and these in turn are produced by the
activation
of free fatty acids through ethyl coa
synthesis
synthetases shown here so here's three
fatty acid
transformed to a fatty acid coa is the
active form of
fatty acid and these
fatty acid coas are subsequently
attached to form diazophospholipids
by so transferases so these acid
transferases
take the activated fatty acids and add
them to
lysophospholipid shown here which
results in a diastole phospholipid with
two fatty acids
shown here so
and these phospholipids present in the
membranes
are the precursors for arachidonic acid
which in turn is used
for the synthesis of icosanoids and
prostaglandins
so now when the authors knock out the
acyl coa
synthase this one here
they observe a reduction in arachidonic
acid containing phospholipids and this
result
is shown here so you see here mainly in
phosphatidylinositol and phosphatidyl
ethanolamine a reduction in those lipid
species
that actually contain arachidonic acid
shown here so here you see
the reduction in all these organic acid
containing lipid species
they went on then to knock out also the
is
so transferase and cells and observe a
decrease
in prostaglandin levels so actually by
interfering with the synthesis of the
phospholipids
they end up with a reduction in
prostaglandins
they same they actually saw with the
knockdown of the acyl-coa synthetase
that means that inhibiting the synthesis
of the
arachidonic acid precursors leads to the
reduction
of prostaglandins
in vivo this knockout actually reduces
the tumor burden
of mice carrying xenographs that's shown
here in panel a you see here
the knockout condition two more burden
shown on the y axis is much lower than
in the control conditions
furthermore this knockout also improves
the survival of these mice as shown here
in panel b
so you see here the blue line and the
knockout the mice live much longer
than in the control condition
in conclusion in this study lipidomics
was integral to elucidate
that the ethyl coa synthetase acsl3 and
the essel
transform transferase alpi
a regular cancer cell proliferation by
affecting prostaglandin synthesis
the authors speculate about targeting
this axis to selectively target
tumor-derived prostaglandin synthesis
as a potential treatment strategy and
the use of this axis is biomarker for
personalized anti-cancer treatment and
human lung tumors
in summary i have given you an
introduction to lipids
and epidemics and how lipidomics was
used to identify lipid biomarkers for
obesity
and to unravel disease mechanisms and
cancer if you're interested in further
details and would like to discuss
specific applications
please contact us at info lipotype.com
thank you for your attention and goodbye